so that's your biggest fear
utah
a greedy boyfriend a user a greedy
new husband
a user
okay
i would like you to promise me that that
will never happen
cody brown revealing his biggest fear
about christine leaving their plural
marriage on the season premiere of
sister wives there's five of us very
five different thinking adults who are
trying to raise kids together and have a
family together
and we don't see eye to eye on all
things season 17 dives right into cody
confronting christine about moving his
stuff out of their house because she
wants to end their 25-year marriage i
really don't want cody in my room it's
gotten to the point where
his presence
just
just gives me anxiety
cody's made it clear to christine he
doesn't want an intimate relationship
and now she's letting him know she
doesn't want one either i'm not
interested in intimate marriage with you
anymore
even if you said at this point we could
have intimacy again i wouldn't believe
it for a second
i
really like living separate i like my
own space i like my own autonomy i feel
like i like me better now as and i just
feel like i've been able to
really
like raise my kids how i want to
but the thing is cody doesn't want to
let christine go why are you insisting
on holding on to me
i'm why
whoa this isn't working cody you said it
wasn't working too
you said you were not i think it's not
working in me
i think we should be trying to work
towards reconciliation for the sake of
our kids i think it's bad timing i'm not
in place where i i say hey to a wife i'm
leaving you that's just never going to
happen
um it's just not you know
if if our relationship isn't good then
we either figure out how to work it out
or or whatever so then cody offers
christine this solution you get married
to somebody else you can bring them here
and they can become part of the family
you don't break up the family with what
you're trying to do
if you're a grown-up
grown-ups do that
but he kinda takes it back sharing with
her what he's afraid might happen you
take truly and you go to utah
the most polygamy unfriendly state in
the union
you get a boyfriend who wants some of
our money
and between you
your boyfriend in the state of utah
i lose any access to truly
and all my money
because um
i've seen it happen to
many many people
so that's your biggest fear
utah
a greedy boyfriend a user a greedy new
husband
a user
okay
i would like you to promise me that that
will never happen
it's not gonna happen promise
i promise
yeah and that moment confirmed to
christine she made the right decision
because he's not safe for me
he's uh can you sorry that was really
he's not safe for me
i don't think there's no doubt in my
mind that i've chosen correctly here so
for us plural marriage doesn't work
for us marriage to someone
it's been 10 months since christine left
cody and she's since shared she's done
with polygamy i really have more of an
independence in august she told people
quote i started thinking maybe this
isn't working for me and then i stopped
believing in polygamy i realized i
didn't really want to live it anymore i
didn't like sharing a husband or feeling
like i wasn't important
[Music]